oh bien on va faire une archive ue dans
les cauchemars
il
je suis pas fils de six mois non c'est
moi ou protection des squales
c'est shakespeare bafia oui maintenant
attention vous pensez à quoi là à
l'instant où plaisir d'être avec vous en
ce jour et on va les laisser
c'est vrai que je ne sais pas c'est très
décontracté l'ambiance meilleur très
bien je suis vraiment je suis ravi
qu'ils soient ravis qu'elle soit ravi
suivant quand vous étiez de petites vous
auriez aimé ressemble et actis le chef
mais j'aurais voulu ressembler asim -
j'en prends le chamarel palois ou alors
à elie semoun je suis plus proche
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois il n'y a pas très longtemps
sur scène oui oui le spectacle au dôme
qui présentait sa compte alors je me
suis laissé aller dans le personnage de
camille oui et ça se voit que changeriez
vous en vous si vous aviez une baguette
magique
pourquoi j'aimerais bien qu'il soit bleu
ça c'est l'enseignant medivh vrais bleus
voilà on est authentique
quel est le péché qui vous tente le plus
l'appareil
ben oui comme tous les gens sur actifs
sur l'île tranche qu'est ce que vous
diriez de plus négatif sur vous ça fait
pas vous savez pas choisir vos chemises
il faut dire sabotier et que je me taise
ce qui peut être médiatisé moi c'est mon
enveloppe charmed
on a l'impression que c'est quelqu'un de
dur sensible je crois que c'est ça qui
avez vous le plus envie d'épater ou amen
qu'avez-vous fait que nous ne sachions
pas en la plein de choses mais justement
vise à redire à cette chasse est un
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait du cinéma
la wii non ça va sortir l'excusé avec
florent pagny france a toujours été une
super expérience
je le savais moi votre vote j'ai chanté
une fois sur scène avec jean claude
dreyfus
ah oui oui ça c'est beau on arrive
maintenant la question jacques chancel à
ckoi le principe
et dieu dans tout ça lui donne c'est
bien si il reste à sa place et moi la
mienne
ah bon à ce mois là ouais ouais j'aurais
ils comptent pas se déplacer de trois
jours
du balai